how much is a table he goes 150 bucks
and I go we'll take it but in seventh
grade when I did a baseball card show
and the table cost 150 bucks
and I said yet me and my two friends
Jason Riker and John shirt shack big
shout out to you guys we went to the
Phillipsburg Mall we all agreed in a
three-way pack in John churchek's mom's
car that if a table costs more than 40
bucks we're not doing the show BAM
I walk up
the dealer walks out he's six foot five
400 pounds one of the most intimidating
men I've ever seen we look up to him we
say how much is a table he goes 150
bucks and I go we'll take it John and
Jason ship their pants I say I'll take
care of it I pay for it I was scared
shitless myself the first hour of the
first show I sell a hundred dollars
worth of cards and I knew